foreign
we're learning more about the suspect
charged with stabbing four University of
Idaho students to death Brian coburger
appeared in the Idaho court yesterday he
has not entered a plea yet according to
an affidavit unsealed Thursday DNA was
found at the crime scene on a knife
sheath near one of the victims
investigators also detail a chilling
interview with the surviving roommate
she said she heard crying inside the
house the night of the murders and she
saw men dressed in black clothing and
wearing a mask walked past her bedroom
for this week's 48 Hours correspondent
Peter Van Zant spoke to Kohlberg's
friends and colleagues
before his arrest Brian kohlberger was
studying for a PhD in criminology and
was a teaching assistant in the
Department of Criminal Justice at
Washington State University roughly
eight miles from the scene of the crimes
Benjamin Roberts took four classes with
coburger and thought he was highly
intelligent he seemed very comfortable
around other people he was fairly quick
to offer his opinion and thoughts this
is out of character for Brian these
allegations Monroe County public
defender Jason labar represented
coburger at his extradition hearing and
has spent time with his parents and two
older sisters the family would want the
general public to know that Brian is a
caring son and brother co-burger and his
sisters grew up in a small town in the
Pocono Mountains his father was a
maintenance worker and his mother worked
in the school system Brian was really
funny he wasn't outgoing at all he was
but he also wasn't shy Brie who asked us
not to use her last name says she met
coburger in high school when he was an
average student with only a few close
friends in his yearbook photo the
caption says coburger aspired to be an
Army Ranger however he was an overweight
kid so he did get bullied a lot but all
that changed says friend Casey Arts when
in his senior year coburger lost about
100 pounds it was after that weight loss
that a lot of people
noticed a huge switch in him my brother
has since come out to say that even
though they were friends Brian bullied
him he would put him in like choke holds
and stuff like that Marie claims that's
also when coburger started using heroin
you just saw him becoming more
self-destructive Casey says she last saw
coburger in 2017. when it appeared that
he was sober and focused on his new
passion criminology Bree says many are
now left wondering where did it go wrong
what happened
[Music]
Peter Van Zant joins us now from outside
the courthouse in Moscow Idaho good
morning Peter how are you doing
hey Nate I'm doing all right so
coburger's interest in criminology makes
this case Standale but we are now
hearing that he once applied for an
internship at a police department what
more can you tell us about that
well in the fall of 2022 coburger
applied for an internship with the
Pullman Police Department was which is
about eight nine miles from where these
Grizzly murders occurred and some people
here are now wondering was he studying
the law to one day help prevent crime or
was he trying to come up with the
perfect crime and keep in mind that I
interviewed one of the fathers of of
these four kids who was convinced that
this was a meticulously planned murder
and not an act of passion
thank you so much we appreciate you
looking forward to your report and you
can see Peter's report the Idaho student
murders on 48 hours tomorrow night at 10
9 Central right here on CBS and
streaming on our service Paramount Plus